MARTIN AGUINIS: Do you want
to learn a fun new skill,
meet other cool people,
and potentially win
prizes of up to $10,000?
EMILY FORTUNA: Flutter
Create is exactly that--
an opportunity to explore
and create a new user
experience with Flutter
in 5 kilobytes or less.
MARTIN AGUINIS: Regardless
of your experience,
with Flutter, you can easily
create beautiful apps.
Just bring your imagination.
You can submit your creations
on flutter.dev/create through
early April.
So head over to the site
to get started soon.
EMILY FORTUNA: We and the rest
of the Flutter team at Google
look forward to seeing
what you create.
So have fun.
[MUSIC PLAYING]